thank you
okay I guess we'll get started um so
thank you everyone for joining us for
the first talk of the morning
um it's a pleasure to introduce Greg
Valiant who is a professor of computer
science at Stanford
um as I understand he works on
algorithms machine learning statistics
information Theory and the combination
of all of those things and today uh
we'll hear him talk about in context
learning
so uh I'm
going to talk about some concrete work
but uh the the overall talk is going to
embed the concrete work into much more
abstract questions in that sense I hope
this is more of a discussion um feel
free to talk to me if there's anything I
say that you want
so the concrete work uh the talk is uh
collaborations with uh
Demetrius and Percy
um
good
okay so so uh yeah we all know about the
serving context
learning
um
and again the the sort of interesting
part about in context learning is that
it appears that you're learning
something even though none of the
weights in your model are being updated
right
um so yeah at different times things
like chat GPC could do a good job of
this or not but uh you know think think
of this sort of example right so I say
like nine minus two equals 11 13 minus
seven equals twenty blah blah blah
what's four minus one
five okay right so so in this case
you've uh you know you've kind of
learned that well by minus I actually
mean Plus
and um you know most people can do this
okay
um you know maybe the very best language
models can do this
um I mean Abraham Lincoln said that if
you call uh
it's true yeah yeah so uh
yeah
okay so we'll come back to this sort of
thing um yeah
um I mean very concretely we'll come
back to
maybe this question of what does it mean
when your prompt is conditioning on some
ludicrous hypothetical right like what
do you do then
um
but these are like the more kind of
traditional sorts of in context learning
examples you see bananas yellow
spinaches to Green carrot is probably
Orange
um
uh but you can also do things like this
so uh let's play this game so dog is
five Mouse is three and just one horses
seven but what's a whale
nine nine yeah okay good uh yeah so
maybe this corresponds to size you could
also maybe this corresponds to longevity
or something like that but um you know
um and uh people are pretty good at this
even kids are okay at this large
language models yeah
you know the uh
uh maybe the very best ones can sort of
do some of these things
um and okay so so in these three things
like in what sense is the in context
learning learning something well it's
learning something about my intent right
so me the person who made this prompt I
have something go some rule in my head
and then a very concrete sense the model
is learning this thing that's in my head
this model in my head
um and again it's not updating any of
its weights in the in the um
okay and then also I guess I would also
argue that you know in context learning
should it when you're saying context
learning we should mean more than just
this sort of stuff we should also mean
things like you know suppose I I try to
teach you something I just pick some
random thing uh so fava bean plants they
fix nitrogen they take nitrogen from the
air and two and they convert into
ammonium and H3 that's fixed in the soil
that then can be used by subsequent uh
plants that like to that like nitrogen
but can't directly get it from the air
given this how could a farmer you know
what could a farmer do to reduce the
amount of nitrogen fertilizer they need
to buy
they say well maybe they can plant these
fava bean plants instead of
um before they plant their other stuff
um and I can even you know based on this
thing that I supposedly taught you I can
even ask you some some so deeper
questions too right like
um given that plants like nitrogen if
they can't get it from the air in what
form do they find it in the soil
well you think maybe they find it in the
form of ammonium
I don't know if that's completely true
but this is sort of uh you know I've
taught you something and you can
manipulate it and come up with
non-trivial statements as a function of
this let's also call this in context
learning none of your synapses have been
updated in the process of this you just
none of your weights have changed but
you can still
um
do some
here's if you've learned what I've what
I've said and you can manipulate it
good okay so so one of the big questions
underlying the like the concrete work
I'll talk about is this question of do
look good language models human or
computer
um must they inherently be able to do in
context learning
so um is it true that like any good
language model any model where you know
you talk to it and it seems like it's
doing a good job talking back
doesn't need to be able to do this sort
of encounter
um so there are lots of questions so so
if so if all good language models do
this
um well one question is like what uh
what actual learning algorithms have
been encoded in these fixed weights
um
slightly more refined version of asking
this
never mind the algorithms but like what
sorts of function classes uh can they
learn context
or do they learn in context
um and then you know there are these
kind of
maybe slightly harder to probe questions
but that I think are maybe even more
interesting
um so if say the large uh you know
trained language models
um if they do kind of inherently do this
in context learning how are the sorts of
function thing function classes that
they can do in context learning on how
are these included or related to the
training course
um
and then I guess another question is
what does a good language model look
like
I can't do this so suppose you have a
really good language model or as good of
a language model as possible given that
it can't really do this sort of in
context learning
what does it look like does it look
embarrassingly terrible or not
um
okay um and then you know if
good language models don't necessarily
need to have a great in context learning
ability
um but one natural thing is can language
models be improved if you sort of give
them the ability to do in context
learning
and then of course there's a question of
how do you give a large language model
this ability
um
um I'm just curious how many people
think that language models a good
language model inherently needs to be
able to learn without
uh
without sort of updating any weights or
Without Really uh doing any real estate
how many people think that's not the
case
um
okay and then uh maybe at a
slight slightly different to a question
which I think from a theory standpoint
is pretty interesting from a practical
standpoint
um
it's not exactly clear what we mean but
um what sorts of tasks inherently
require weight updates to solve
effectively
so
yeah and I'll talk about this a bit more
at the very end on the analog for humans
is probably this question of you know
what tasks require sleep to learn right
so you know broadly speaking synaptic
you know your your brain doesn't do that
much during the daytime you can remember
things and so on but at night that's
when maybe you know synapse strengths
change that's where memories are
Consolidated and all this there's a huge
volume of work in the you know cog's eye
and uh and psych literatures um you know
looking at what sorts of tasks can be
benefited from sleep and and they you
know what goes on is very complicated
there are lots of different things that
happen
um but um you know there are lots of
experiments where
yo you sort of taught something and then
you know half the people in the
experiment are given some relaxing you
know they say take a break for two hours
we'll come back the other half are put
to sleep and given like a one hour nap
um and then you know you do something
after after they wake up and there are
lots of tasks where like even a nap is
much more effective at improving your
ability than just taking a break or
doing a relaxing I think um not just
tasks related to memory consolidation
like people
decent understanding of the role of the
pre-memory consolidation but other other
sorts of things too
um
a bit later in the talking about I'll
briefly discuss for large language
models like uh
how much better is it if you allow the
weights to change versus just doing
things
okay so going to the the
large language model
um I guess there is this question of can
large language models really perform in
context learning
um and the reason this isn't such a
silly question is the larger models are
uh you know do appear to be better at in
context learning and these larger models
I mean
there's more weird fine-tuning and you
know prompt engineering that is pretty
opaque at least I don't I don't know
what they're doing
um and the training Corpus is yeah I
don't know that much about the training
Corpus so it's not clear what tasks are
already in the training Corp this or
it's not
um
so you know there is still this question
to what extent is this apparent ability
to do in context learning just to just a
mirage or a function of the training
Corpus
so at least the very first question is
you know can we train
a model
um to do in context learning in a real
sense where we're going to train this
thing from scratch there's no hidden
data sets we know exactly what we're
training on there's no fine-tuning
um it's not uh in context learning it's
not going to be some function of prompt
engineering it's okay can we at least
train a model to to do this that's the
first question
okay so let me let me uh
approving this question then we'll go
back to some of the higher level
questions are we all on unword
okay so so what does it mean to to kind
of formally do in context learning for
some specific function class
um
well so we'll we'll have some
distribution these effects is going to
be a distribution over examples
think of these examples maybe these are
just vectors
something else
we're going to have a distribution of
our functions
which map
you know uh an example
um through some set
and then we can form a prompt as you
know here's our example gone from our
distribution of examples here's the
label
drawn by first selecting a function from
this distribution and then using that
function to label our example another
example another label and so on
and then at the end of our prompt we
have our query and we just want to know
you know what this function applied to
our query point
and you know we'll train a model M and
we can see that this model can do in
context learning it can learn this uh
um
set of functions or this class of
functions with respect to this
distribution and this distribution
if you know with with the
um
in expectation
when you cook up a prompt like this from
this distribution
you get the something like the right
label for this so this is like the
think of it as sort of a pack uh
um
the context yeah it's a typical hacking
context floor
in a particular our model m is uh
yeah it's a fixed model nothing it's not
being uh
no weights are being updated as it jumps
through the prompt
okay so um
this is just the same slide um so what
function classes are we going to look at
well we're going to start by looking at
all the you know the very simple
function classes that a theorist might
first write down so we'll look at first
just linear linear functions in D
dimensions
we'll also look at some small you know
small learning the set of small decision
trees
um
we'll do a few other simple function
classes
um
okay so the first question maybe more
concretely instantiated can we train a
model
maybe a Transformer
maybe lstm maybe even simpler things
that's fully connected deep neural
network to in context learn these these
basic function classes with respect to
Natural distributions over here
so let me begin with uh Transformer
stuff
um
so uh so we look at kind of gp2 gpd2
style transform architecture
um we looked at different size models
but most of our experiments are
a model with roughly 20 million
parameters
um
smaller models are okay too but at some
point things degrade
um
and
fairly convenient you you know you put
your prompt in your label your example
label example label
and then we're just going to look at you
know
embeddings of should be the label and
crucially like like what comes out here
um this is like a decoder only
architecture this this kind of thing
this label here is only a function of
what comes up through the the second
input
so evaluating the the sort of uh
uh the loss you know see well how good
is it at predicting the second label the
label given one example the label given
two examples and so on
um
okay so what do people think is going to
happen
of course it learns right
um
okay so uh
the natural starting place the
distribution of our examples is just
going to be an identity covariance
the dimensions
um are linear functions we're going to
pick the weight Vector uniformly from
again a d dimensional identity
covariance calcium
and I guess this figure will be for 20
dimensional linear functions we can talk
about some scaling laws with the
dimension but maybe I won't do that
since I think Surya will do a better job
a more thorough job of that sort of
thing
okay so this is just an empirical plot
of
like the the uh the optimal the base
optimal learner which is just doing
least squares
so once you have 20
um uh once you have like 20 label points
in your context you should be getting
error zero
that you've learned your linear function
and this is roughly how our you know
your squared error should decrease
linearly
the bumps are just because this is a
empirical
so this is a Transformer that you
specifically trained on this meta
learning problem uh yes yeah yeah yeah
so this is this is a based on these
squares but yeah we're gonna we're
training a Transformer from scratch to
learn how to do linear regression yeah
in context
um
um so I'll talk a bit more about what
the least squares
like like what what is the regression
algorithm a little bit
um okay so so this this orange line
which is basically on top of the Blue
Line This is what the Transformer ends
up doing so it's um
uh
certainly yeah with respect to this
distribution of of uh examples it
appears to be basically doing regression
right
so you input uh
yeah
um good so so so uh
yeah so so we've we've trained this
Transformer by first oh yeah okay
um into the previous size right
so how do we train the Transformer we
randomly initialize it and then we pick
a random
um function
from you know it does it these random
d-dimensional vector
we generate this uh to a prompt
we're picking all these X's randomly and
then we do you know training update on
the loss that says yeah what comes out
here should be uh this f of x one what
comes out here it should be this F of X2
and so on and then the next example we
pick a new random function a new random
linear functions in the class a new
random example and so on
you know learn this you just input
numbers
put numbers yeah so we're training this
from scratch so it doesn't know language
it doesn't know it doesn't know anything
so we're just plugging in these messages
um yeah so I mean the the loss
is really just a squared error on its
kind of these predictions
um yeah the loss is the the squared
error
so so like what comes out here which is
some function of
the first K uh K minus one labeled
example then the case labeled example
the loss here is just a squared error on
the on the label for this last one
throughout this process are the weights
changing in this case
uh so during training it's it's changing
but then when we when we evaluate things
we fixed the model we fixed the weights
now we pick a new function
so this distribution a new set of
however many examples
we make that prompt and then we just no
weights change we just give that prompt
pump it through the Transformer and see
what the label is
giving you for the for the for the last
or for the ice data point
this tells you how accurately you're
doing as a function of the number of
in-context data points you've given it
and you know as as as one would have
hoped yeah when you're giving it the
dimension labeled examples it's
basically figured out the linear
function
isn't this just supervised learning
examples and then you give it a new one
and you have it
um predict the output
uh
good so so you're saying like uh why am
I calling this in context learning
supervised learning so it did but the
supervised learning problem it's not
learn the linear function it's learn
regression that's the difference
usually when you think about supervised
learning for linear function there is
one linear function I give you a bunch
of examples
and you're updating weights to try to
learn that function
here the function you're trying to learn
is the regression function that Maps a
bunch of labeled uh a new random linear
function a bigger class but a still
supervised learning yes of course of
course yeah
are you passing those K uh examples in
as like one prompt uh or are they like
like K separate prompts
um the uh
like in the last slide when you when you
were doing the training
oh so each function so you sample a
function yeah you make one prompt from
that function okay that's all of your K
training data points that's like a
single yeah say we just do like 40 yeah
X's per per function that's one problem
okay let me sample a new function make
new 40 new X's labeled that function if
that's another problem and the target is
like a k dimensional Vector right the
target for the output is like a k
dimensional vector
um
the dimensionality the yeah think of it
as for each in context
X there's just one real number that
we're trying to
would it be
would it make sense to try and learn the
coefficients of progression instead of
just trying to predict the whole output
of it like could you help it along by
giving it final I guess that's is that
what the linear layer at the end is
doing
um okay so this is a good question if if
you if you say you must learn a linear
function as represented by by these
coefficients let's have a much easier
problem in the sense that you're saying
find these coefficients such that
um you know when you just do inner
product of this with your
examples you're getting these labels so
so that's uh that's what makes things
much easier here it's you can do
whatever weird thing it it wants
um but yeah if you want to just start
unpacking what algorithm does it
represent then um
so can one conclude that there's some
part inside the transform into this that
knows about linear functions and trying
that out and then it it agrees with the
data well
um
I mean I mean you know how do you solve
regression like one thing is you do this
you know you kind of do gaussian
elimination something like that does
that know about linear functions sort of
but not you know was it trained in
algebra no no no no no no no no
it's no no it's literally just trained
on these you know in goes your example
it was just chat
sure sure but it's it's randomly it's
that architecture
but it's only been trained on what we
give it there's no language
it hasn't yeah
my question is related to uh whether
this is in contact so
Network to feed this data set
Candace new networks you'll perform
Leader Impression and if so can we
also
good okay so we'll sort of come to this
um so the answer so I tried this a
little bit for fully connected neural
networks it seems harder to train we
also did this with lstms
and it's sort of it works but yeah I
don't think there's anything special
about Transformers here
we will come to that
um
so uh
you could say you know to what extent is
this really doing the right thing or
maybe it's just doing some like
smoke and mirrors if you've made up some
reasonable heuristics of like fake ways
it could be doing this like it's looking
at some nearest neighbor and the
training said it gave you gave it and so
on like these things are terrible or
maybe it's just doing some sort of a
very low degree averaging algorithm yeah
so it seems like it's doing something
fundamental and we'll we'll probe this a
bit more
um
okay just now so for more complex
function classes suppose instead of
linear functions suppose we do sparse
linear functions okay so if you have a
linear function but I tell you
know I promise you that
um you know only on the K of the
coordinates are non-zero
um then the number of examples you need
is just count K Times log the dimension
um and things like lasso one regularized
regression exploit that
um and lo and behold you know
um Transformers seem to be doing
basically as well as as
lasso for these sparse things
um
bunch of interesting
we're not
like we don't tell it that the true
model is sparse like it just we just
give it these
random sparse function with labels and
of course function of labels and then we
give it a bunch of labeled examples
According to some new random sparse
function and it's doing the right labels
um
so curiously when you when you train
this the the loss curve so it's flat for
a long time and then it jumps down
and at that point it's figured out
regression but it doesn't know how to
leverage Varsity then it's flat for a
really long time
and then it jumps down once it's figured
out how to exploit sparsity
yeah this like two-step
uh
um
so if you you know that the idea you
have to give it this regularizer
otherwise it will overfit
through tons and tons of data at it
right so that really helps it
so with this are you throwing enough
data at it that it you know it's it's
reasonable that even even without the
regularizer
like regression out with behind the
zeros find the scarcity
oh so so sorry so this is a part of so
between the thing and we're saying how
does the air and its predictions
decrease as the number of x's in this
context increases so this blue line is
if you just did regression we're still
in 20 Dimensions so with 20 Dimensions
you'd learn the thing
and this curve is sort of what you get
if you leverage you know I forget if
it's these parts or four sparse or
something like that but you know if you
leverage that sparsity of your last so
yeah with like 10 examples you can do
well it's gonna be kind of weird right
that it's actually inferring a prior
when you haven't told it about the prior
I guess yeah yeah
if you have any insight into how that's
happening
um
but I'll see a couple words on that in a
sec but the short answer is I mean well
uh
for small decision trees we're doing
very well much better than even things
like XD boost which is kind of you know
what most people would think of as
our state-of-the-art decision tree
learner
um uh
if the function
like the function classes we sample a
random we randomly initialize a two
layer neural network and we use that to
label our data points
we can learn that function
and the reference line here is if you
were to train a two-layer network via
gradient descent over the context
so where you're updating the weights
and you know the Transformer is doing
about the same
as that right so so we're sort of
comparing this Transformer where none of
the weights are changing
to what you would do if you wanted to
learn this function you'd randomly
initialize a uh you know two layer
neural network and you train it via
gradient descent to match these labels
and the and the reference line
uh yeah did you train one network for
each of these different
things or is it one uh yeah so we we did
it
separately randomly initialized things
for each of them although if you did you
know you don't
you probably didn't need to do that you
could do one network that would do all
of them all three yeah
yeah let's see so um
uh these are
um
yeah I think just each node you pick a
random so this is the
you're still in D dimensional space but
you pick like a random coordinate and
maybe a random threshold
and just build this random decision tree
so the distribution of the decision
trees
yeah it's doing something tailored to
that distribution in the sense that XG
boost
even for this distribution like it's not
just doing some naive YouTube building
this no it's doing something different
we can talk more about this actually um
like a theory standpoint like I think
it's doing some interesting uh things
but
right now the training
example and and I mean the number of
incontinent example do training and
testing are identical
the size of the context window yeah yeah
and you don't you do not test for the
generalization
like you need to train fewer examples to
read training and you test for more
examples oh well so so that's like the
number of in-context x's you have
um like the way Transformers work they
they get you know each number of x's
it's trying to do the label given things
before that so in that sense it's doing
its best to learn given as few in
context examples as possible
okay so it's sort of uh you know
and yeah if we give it many more well
that like that's bigger than our context
window so that doesn't even like make
sense
but
but I guess is
if we train for for the contact side of
five and you test for contact size of
1080 and it gets better every single
example is given which I've been testing
for a context size of 10 like it doesn't
even make sense if we're sticking this
whole context in like that's the input
I think these things have a fixed
context yeah right but I know what you
mean like it but yeah so what's the size
of the two layer Network in relation to
the transport
oh these are these are small
I'm curious if you found a task or like
a function class where the
algorithm learned
and neural net
trained with s3d okay so so uh I'll do
some comparisons with um lstms I'm not
going to do comparisons with fully
connected detail that works but I
think that that comparison is worth
doing but uh
okay
um
let me very quickly just just for people
who I mean this is sort of interesting
maybe
um for uh for regression
um it really speeds things speeds up
training to do a curriculum learning and
the natural curriculum is you start by
just giving it like much lower
dimensional basically like version one
example then Dimension two and so on
um and you sort of build up the
dimensionality to the final
dimensionality
um so these are some plots uh
the Orange Line these are your training
losses
um
without curriculum is orange line with
curriculum is this blue line the reason
it dips down is because you're like
you're for lower dimensional things
um it's an easier problem your training
loss actually should be lower okay so so
the fact that item goes up reflects the
fact that the problem is getting harder
as the curriculum is ramping up
but um you know this this first plot
this is uh
yeah if the dimension is 10 without a
curriculum eventually you learn it's
fine you mentioned 20 it takes longer to
learn without a curriculum 30 Dimensions
four dimensions with 50 Dimensions like
uh maybe we you know you need to run it
really long without a curriculum to get
it sort of curiously the curriculum
speeds up training but it doesn't really
improve your final performance
um
okay and just a note on kind of
generalization there's a difference the
final performance like does it ever get
stuck on the camera
uh I mean there's some weird stuff like
this little thing but
um
when you see plateaus you mentioned like
with lasso
um like learning regression and sparsity
do you see those pleches consistently or
just something yeah it's just like
speeding up training helps if you don't
know how many plateaus there are in a
learning problem
um I learned a few days ago that these
large language models have trouble
multiplying three-digit numbers and
getting them accurately
so how is it doing the linear regression
the mathematics of linear regression
here
oh well like I said this multiplying
three digit numbers the hard part is
that you're giving it in terms of the
digits it needs to figure out how to
carry all that stuff but you know these
networks like uh
they're allowed to multiply real numbers
right like like the weights get
multiplied and so on so you're putting
the numbers in the actual neurons here
um I mean the input is a vector and
these layers you know you multiply these
matrices this is a vector and it's a
number
then yeah then because certain numbers
have
a unique word associated with it or how
does it yeah
I don't understand the difference oh
that there's no um the hard part about
multiplication for numbers is the fact
that like people have this weird
abstract representation of numbers
that's not inherently the language that
you know is sort of uh
the representation that baked into how
you know Transformers work that's the
hard part right these conventions for
carrying things and so on but um uh
so are you giving the numbers with uh
with uh you know how many digits along I
mean yeah I know these are probably
32-bit representations of numbers
right and and you know computers know
how to multiply 32-bit numbers
internally the order knows how to
tokenize that there's no tokenization I
guess that's the point that's uh I mean
it sort of figures out
uh
uh yeah there's no there's no like
abstract representations
as in language we're giving it these
vectors in ways that it
is
sorry no there's still a question here
because is multiplication A Primitive
operation that it's like allowed in this
model I mean if I think of a standard
neural net I just linear combinations
and you know some non-linear activation
functions
yes
yeah thank you
thank you because these are Transformers
well no I mean for fully connected
things you know they also have inner
products I mean everything has
Enterprise yeah
and
one quick comment so uh it takes a while
to train these things
um like none of the training took more
than a day using a single GPU but um uh
you don't need that many random
functions sampled from your function
class so even with like say 10 000
random linear functions and it's only
seen ten thousand randomly functions
it's still able to generalize to new
um
but that's one thing cereal is going to
talk about
so so this is maybe the punch line right
so we were asking can we train a model
to in context learn function classes
linear functions small decision trees
small neural networks sparse linear
functions and that's the countless yes
with an and my claim is like with enough
training data large enough models
we should expect to learn like phase
optimal algorithm I feel like this is
the expectation that whatever it's going
to do it really should be doing
something close to the with respect to
the distribution of stuff you train it
on it should be doing basically base
optimally
even when the base optimal algorithm is
complicated like you know lasso doesn't
have a closed form expression or you
know these decision tree algorithms are
probably fairly complicated but we this
is what you should expect
if you're not learning something close
to B is optimal uh you know you need to
you know tweak your hyper parameters
because this is what you should expect
and my claim is this actually holds
pretty broadly not just for Transformers
but for any architecture this is sort of
what you should be expecting
um
so in um there's been a bunch of more
recent papers on this so this is one
posted uh so folks here
um who posted uh just a month ago
um which which kind of starts to try to
make this more more rigorous maybe this
claim um and it sort of shows yeah like
whatever you do you can get these you
can train these things to basically do
the base optimal thing
you contain one model that can do all
these different tasks and it figures out
when it should do it in a big optimal
way and um
okay so given this
I guess the real question there well
okay maybe it's doing these optimal
things but are the Learned algorithms
any good
um
okay so question are the Learned
algorithms any good
um yeah maybe it's doing some base
optimal thing but um maybe the real test
is like is the algorithm doing the right
thing
one way of looking at that is how well
do these algorithms perform on outer
distribution examples
do people buy this sort of buy this
claim I I'm confused by it seems like it
seems like you're learning a super base
it's super optimal because when you did
your linear regression without a you
know sparsity prior when you did that
comparison of lasso to uh you know least
squares regression
your your Transformer was able to figure
out
just by looking at this that some of the
coefficients were zero put them when
when regression wasn't and and you know
least squares regression wasn't at least
squares regression is sort of what I
would consider you know phase optimal in
the absence of having that prior that
sure but if your distribution of
examples only gives you label vectors
where the labels do correspond to sparse
linear functions then with respect to
that distribution the B's optimal thing
is less so with the optimal choice of
regularizing
right but eventually Lee Square finds
that and gets to base optimal right they
oh no no so I guess I mean base Optical
in a sense of given the number of
labeled exams the number sorry the
number of like uh the contact size
it pays optimal for that amount of data
I don't mean it's a mathematotic sense I
really mean like given three labeled
examples there really is saying like
conditional on the distribution of stuff
that I've seen like what's the right
thing here so on just a general argument
of like there's no free lunch or minimum
description length or you know Shannon
optimality or whatever you want to think
about it like there has to be some
Middle Ground like between like where if
um
you know your your network is guessing
that it's a sparse prior but you know at
some point when it actually isn't or you
know or it's guessing that it's not
I'm sort of outperform can't get can't
get there faster than at least quiz
regression all of the time okay
um think of it as you know this this
network it's been trained on this
distribution where it's only ever seen
sparse things
so it does you know in some sense it
knows that you're giving as far as
things it has learned this kind of
Distinction over problems you've given
you've given it a lot of space functions
so it's learned that function that
functions yeah and if you give it a
dense function it'll it'll do garbage
well yeah it's never seen done function
so it has it has learned the prior over
I said okay it's learn the prior over
functions just by having seen a lot of
functions yes
so when you train the Transformer does
this for this cling to be correct
the right in content size they're making
the smallest and content size as
possible but again for the front
no so the claim is like for every size
yes yes smaller than whatever our
maximum context is it is doing the base
Optimum given the first three labeled
examples it's an optimal phase of
nothing given three
and that's what these curves are sort of
showing
I'm going to do the really nice thing to
say like now I agree it is Trivial kind
of thing by saying that uh yeah if it's
a gaussian process right so we know this
is this result that these infinitely
and the counseling process is just a
prior over functions right so it's true
it's kind of it's able to learn that
prior over function so yeah I think that
part that's not obvious is that how it's
able to find the the minimum of the
which seems a bit like a what a
variational autoencoder is doing or
something yeah and why it doesn't get
lost yeah I mean so you know proving
this in a rigorous sense yes
certainly certainly not you know not
obvious but but the claims yeah this is
what you should expect
and based on this the claim is really
like are these algorithms actually good
um claim for any function class or of
particular functions
yeah for any thing that any function
class for any architecture
this is what you should
Transformer that like
like given examples predict models
others like
like
yes yeah yeah
if it doesn't work make it make it
bigger paint it longer
uh okay good so so uh
okay so we had a look at um
you know four uh
think of this as now we've changed this
these things and now we're looking at um
prompts we're looking at things that are
sort of basically in the measure zero
subset we're really probing what the
algorithm has learned outside of the
training distribution
um
in general it seems to do quite well let
me not talk about this now I'll talk
about this in two slides when there's an
extra Dimension together
um
okay okay so so
suppose instead of Transformers you use
lstms
um for the same task this this Orange
Line This lstm again this is for the
distribution of stuff that you've came
up and you might say well it's a little
worse when you have exactly 20 examples
we're training in 20 Dimension sorry the
linear function is 20 dimensional so you
know there should be this sharp Kink
here lstms it's a little bit worse but
it's not so bad it's pretty close to the
space optimal
um
okay but then if you start probing what
lstms have actually learned what their
algorithm is you start to see that it's
actually more like smoke and mirrors
whereas the Transformer seems to have
learned something really similar to uh
least squares regression
and one way to see this is if you look
at um
so we've seen this thing on noiseless
linear regression
what happens if you give it
um you know the slightly noisy labels
so we know that this orange curve
um is least squares regression we know
it has this double descent phenomenon
right so if I give you exactly D points
label the coin to linear classifier and
I add a tiny bit of noise to the labels
and I fit that with a linear classifier
that new linear classifier is almost
uncorrelated with the true linear
classifier
how many people really parse what I just
said
you're saying no this is what double
descent means I'm sorry
I'm sorry pick a linear classifier
okay okay so pick it
um pick a linear model the D dimensions
say you pick D random
unit vectors label them according to
this linear classifier
okay if you fit these labeled points you
get your linear model back D dimensions
g-dimensional then okay now add a tiny
amount of noise to the d labels
labels
don't change the X's but the why is this
linear function evaluated out of X is
add a tiny bit bit of noise to these
labels
and and then fit those noisy labels with
your linear function find a linear
function that goes through these d
new labeled points
how much is this new linear function
different from the true linear model
the claim is even for a tiny amount of
noise these things become almost
uncorrelated
how many people like yes this is double
descent I understand this I've seen this
how many people this sounds okay okay
this is great so uh so basically we're
saying suppose you're doing regression
how ill-conditioned is this in the case
where you have exactly the labels
and think of it this way suppose you
have D minus one points
and now the death Point arrives
um
do you minus one points There's One
Direction where you have no variance
this D point
it only sticks a tiny bit in this
missing Direction
so for the D minus 1.2 is
so you're extremely terribly conditioned
if you pick D points from a
random unit vectors there is some the
the smallest eigenvalue of the
covariance is really small
which means that when you do regression
it's going to be poorly conditioned but
this is the sort of curve you get
for re for regression that literally
like if you have a little tiny constant
amount of noise say exactly the examples
basically you fit these noisy points
perfectly
but there's no correlation with the true
model for linear regression
okay
for Transformers we get this this blue
we get this sort of double descent
phenomena we get this ill condition
what does that mean that means the
Transformers have learned a very
numerically
you know unstable algorithm a very
sensitive algorithm just like regression
lstms these are two different STM
architectures there's no double descent
what does that mean that means the
algorithms they represent
they don't know what the dimension is
they don't know D
they don't they aren't doing any
complicated inverting a matrix of
examples they're not doing what
regression does where you have this very
numerically sensitive thing instead like
what are algorithms that don't do double
this end fit the best model on some half
of your points fit the best model on
some other half of the points average
all of these things it doesn't matter
whether you have D examples or D plus
one examples everything is smooth you
don't get this numerical instability
in a more formal sense you can say these
lstms are learning some sort of low
degree functions that don't have this
you know instability of inverting a
ill-conditioned matrix of examples that
regression has you could say oh this is
wonderful we have numerical stability
for lstms
but um
but no like like we're training on a
distribution where the right answer is
is a regression
which is numerically unstable
and you know the fact that it's
that uh Transformers have this double
descent is an indication that it really
is doing something resembling kind of
the right algorithm whereas lstms aren't
and this and and this sort of comes back
in the sense of if you start giving it
strange prompts
if you start giving it prompts that are
like out of distribution
Transformers kind of do the right thing
whereas lstms it's not as robust
so one example maybe suppose you give it
a bunch of x's we're in 20 dimensional
space
but all of the X's I give you are in
some 10 dimensional Subspace
Transformers with their kind of you know
numerical instabilities they know that
these things all lie in the low
dimensional Subspace
lstms don't really realize that all of
these prompts are in a loaded all of
these X's are in a low-dimensional
Subspace and that's manifested by some
like bad performance
so if you think about if you need to
orthogonalize a bunch of vectors with
respect to each other that's a very high
degree thing if that's what your
algorithm is doing you do get the sort
of double descent Transformers seem to
be doing this to some extent lstms are
do these Transformers have traditional
encoding
uh yeah yeah so these are like the same
trained traditional encodings
this is more just associate which label
goes with which example
[Music]
algorithm so can I say that this lstm is
not large enough
okay sort of yeah so you know you might
say look this isn't base optimal because
of this Kink here
it's impressive how well it's doing in
distribution given that the algorithm is
like some weird like non-numerically
sensitive thing
right but um uh yeah so okay both in
terms of compute time
like both in terms of them training
money and I think time tuning parameters
we try I think we tried to make lstms
work harder than we tried making
Transformers
given that
you know I
take this so that you know if something
doesn't work it's hard to
be sure it's impossible right so we
tried hard for lstms
but um yeah maybe we just and deeper
bigger
yeah yeah so okay so with small with
small lcms it's terrible these lstms are
10 times bigger than the Transformers if
you go to 100 times bigger it will be
better between it for a thousand times
longer it will be better some of these
issues will probably go away
um
yeah so so that's uh that's what it says
in pink yeah so so uh it seems like
Transformers are better at learning
these have these the the right like high
you know very non-lipshits functions
um yeah
they are better at learning to have
these right algorithms
um and you know a big question is what
property of them enables this are there
better architectures
I think one easy way of saying this is
the the optimal algorithm
is very non-lib shits as a function of
it
and whereas these lcms they're in a much
more legit function of that
okay oh but sorry but this is uh this is
we give it like noisy labels just just
at in context they've been trained in a
noiseless setting
yeah no no if you give a noise then
everything still looks perfect yeah
yeah so uh yeah three more minutes
um good so takeaway is uh maybe yeah we
should expect nearly base optimal
behavior of Arcane models with respect
to whatever distribution of stuff uh we
train them on
um and Things become interesting when
extrapolation
is successful so significantly beyond
the training distribution and that's
really what Surya is going to start
talking about
um and then yeah one big question is
what architectures are especially
successful at doing this and why
um
a couple couple questions so um
one question is
okay so suppose we take for granted that
these models will do based optimal thing
um
what can we learn from that
okay so so one thing which like not many
the theorists in the audience might care
about like are there any nice
distributional information theoretic
theoretical questions where we don't
know the answer and we'd like to know
the answer
one question so how many people know
about like planted Creek
you know your random graph you want to
know uh you know can you can you
efficiently find a a clique in it uh
what how big does a clique need to be
for efficient algorithms
um there's a this problem is phrased
with respect to a distribution of graphs
and you know if you think that we can
train these things to do something
optimal
um you know at least we might be able to
know the answer well what for what size
clicks can you actually solve things
um there are a number of other uh sort
of interesting information theoretic
things that people aren't really sure
about
um how many people there are Chase
reconstruction
uh anyway um so I was gonna ask if there
are if there are
um
there are a bunch of kind of problems
the theory Community Maybe Might care
about that even just knowing what the
right answer is would be helpful and
this might be a nice way of of learning
right now
um
big question so you know here we're
training these Transformers just to do
this kind of learning tasks but what are
the actual implications for language
models do language models do regression
um you know to what extent can they
um
and then also language models you know
beyond this in context learning type
stuff what other algorithmic Primitives
can they do so these large language
models
um they seem very good at binary search
if you can play 20 Questions with chat
GPD and it's very good if you say like
I'm thinking of a number between 1 and
500 million 32 000 blah blah blah blah
you know you guess I'll tell you if it's
higher or lower than my true number
it'll exactly do binary search
is that something they hard-coded maybe
um but uh binary search seems to be a
pretty fundamental algorithmetive that
um people use in conversation
if I say some big stuff you ask
questions and kind of do binary search
to prove what I'm talking about right
um
it's working uh do large language models
can they sort
of
um
and I guess yeah so question like what
sorts of algorithm Primitives can these
language models do and the other
question is the ones where they can't
really do it what happens if you give
them the ability how much better do they
become at language modeling if you give
them this ability and how do you do it
so maybe I'll end
uh
yeah and well okay let me just skip to
one one last question
um
so related to this in context learning
ability is also this kind of metric
question of why are language models
large language models fairly robust to
Outer domain prompts why can we
condition on like kind of a zero measure
subset and still get reasonable Behavior
like image classification all this stuff
we kind of know it's very brittled out
of domain uh so why are what what's
their inherent about language that gives
this robustness
um
and
there it seems like prompt engineering
we're adding cover prefixes even can
improve this sort of robustness
um and maybe both from a theory as well
as sort of soft Theory standpoint I
think it's worth trying to formalize the
power of these uh of prompt engineering
people tend to think of prompt
engineering as just applying Band-Aids
to you know slightly broken aspects of a
language model but I think it's a bit
more fundamental than that
um so maybe just to end with one with
one comment
um
so with people when you ask them a kind
of absurd nonsensical prompt often they
don't do much but you can add a
reasonable
yeah you can do some prompt engineering
to get them to do the right responses so
yeah I mentioned maybe on Monday I made
a stupid comment about you know
anthropologists going to remote Villages
and saying you know suppose there's some
Island uh all of the Bears on the island
are pink Ivan lives on that island if
Ivan sees a bear what color is it
so so you know if you do the logic okay
it must be pink
um and you know you ask some some people
they they don't they don't do this using
and you know people have been doing
these sorts of hypothetical questions
for for a century
um in the maybe 70s and 80s I forget the
name a Harvard uh psychologist was
looking at this in children and the
results are all over the place
but he ended up basically finding that
you know if you if you wanted to know
like at what age do children start to
do these things we basically found that
um you know among among kids whether or
not they say the right thing uh
um you know you can basically make them
do the right thing if you just prefix
things by saying okay let's uh let's
play pretend okay let's make believe
blah blah blah and then they'll do this
absurd hypothetical of some island where
all the Bears are pink and if you don't
do this this was a you know I don't know
what do you want your conditioning on
this absurd thing what do you want me to
do but if you say okay let's play
pretend then do this
um so anyway so I think this like notion
of prompt engineering I think it's much
more fundamental than just like a
Band-Aid over bad language models I
think it's something more fundamental
about how languaging work how language
Works especially when you're
conditioning on these almost measures
your things
um let me in there thank you
[Applause]
thank you Greg for the wonderful talk um
while we get set up for the next talk
um so we can take a few questions
yeah uh in the same way that you have
this nice example where lstm clearly
fails to learn the right
in the same way you have this example
where lstm clearly fails to learn the
right algorithm do you have any clean
isolated examples like this where
Transformer is also doing the wrong
thing
so maybe I'll say it's not that clear
that lstms are doing oh
yeah I'm convinced yeah yeah okay uh
not really no
um but we didn't prove extremely
complicated
um
functions I mean I guess there's the
work out of Harvard showing like very
very non-continuous functions like
parity even then you train it for a very
long time and you can get Transformers
to learn but you can also get fully
connected neural Nets to learn it too
right so um uh yeah so what functions
are super hard I mean I think this is
kind of related to this more general
question of what tasks actually require
weight updates which I didn't get to
talk about much but
um it seems like across the board if you
have a model and you're either going to
do in context learning or you're allowed
to literally like update your weights
the gradient descent over your little in
context examples
also you can think of it as kind of
fine-tuning fine tuning is always better
if you can like update your weights it's
always it's always better
um but um
yeah are there problems where like you
can't go to do anything unless you
update weights
I think that's a really nice question
and that's inherently become
computational
okay
[Applause]
sounds good
foreign